all right you guys don't thought I shot
this video on the same days by Tuesday
video because of my hair but I changed
my shirt out of just pure human courtesy
for you let's start this eight once over
Wednesday and the Oscars happened on
Sunday so I'm wearing a sweatshirt let's
review some fashions away we go Brad and
Angelina looking like not human people
oh you just make me feel so bad
comfort oh they're so pretty and I got
this going on Lady Gaga if Tyler
Oakley's old hair color was a dress it
be this she looks like lavender ice
princess skater queen hips shook so soon
like this and everyone's gonna be frozen
John Stamos John stay most of the night
please
we have a full house Kate Hudson more
like Kate Hudson she's wearing a kid and
making it look elegant I wanted to do
that Wow
Kate you always do this to me you always
take my ideas home fries my idea
no that was drew Barrymore was it I
don't know what are you doing Jennifer
Lawrence you win this time and Hathaway
laughs I saw this photo I thought that
she put on like a black dress and then
somehow spilled glue all over the top
part of her body and then fell into a
pile of tinfoil but only on the top half
excellent choice
Charlie's give us a chance to find
imperfections in you I got this going on
though Emma Watson looking cute a little
gothic a little tank top long skirt
action maybe full dress I don't know I
don't hate it
Benedict Cumberbatch apparently he's the
star of the night with this photo bomb
of YouTube
his name is Benedict cumberpatch he's
got the amazing sense of humor and great
legs for jumping oh oh
something's happening in my body
feelings cate blanchett looks like
everyone just hung their keys up on her
very beautiful stunning even at least
everyone will be able to find their keys
at the end of the night Sandra Bullock
just
this looks good but that's the second
thing yes cuz I know gravity was very
good movie Meryl Streep had how that's
what I want to age like I bet she's a
great drinker
leonardo dicaprio tobey da i don't know
how to pronounce your last name the
correct way so I'm just calling her
Lupita she has great style she wears
solid colors all the time
and you know what that is solid uh it's
ask wimp attack of the squib she looks
like she's having a great time uh do I
follow the yellow brick road to Emerald
City because I don't want to go home I
bet she's a great drink or two Johnny
weird Tara Lipinsky this might get weird
y'all it did overall I give the Oscars
fashions like four to five things
everyone look pretty good
very elegant elegance is back
I don't know I'm looking I'm just sure
to look at that back in my head in that
mirror dirty everything I own is dirty
GG make resolutions in March spring
cleaning that should happen for me
in so many ways camp Takota calm